the Joe Rogan experience wasn't even a
little bit more protected and leased by
the filmmaker I thought the filmmaker
kind of threw him under the bus a little
bit but that's just you know how so he
wanted to be in the film yeah I know it
was weird though it started to feel
weird I felt like um I don't know I mean
like the Faculty of protective but
changing his name the Russians knew who
he was
yeah I don't know I just I just felt
like it was um uh-huh
I felt like it was a little reckless as
a filmmaker you know I just felt like
God it was it what would you do
differently
it's tell you the truth I really I
really don't know what I would do
differently I just felt like man this
guy like well as I'm watching it going
like man this guy's gonna get in a lot
of trouble he's gonna get killed because
of this he threw me and so I don't know
maybe I did I don't know maybe I do
maybe I'm just talking on my ass you
weren't like rigging the Olympics yeah
now what what changed after that was
that the Russians essentially are barred
from the Olympics and now they compete
on the olympic fire what's interesting
is we they had Don Catlin in there and
Don catlins guy for America that does
the same thing does he and he was gonna
he was going to be the first guy
remember then he backed out and he said
I'll give you the Russian guy because he
knew the Russian guy does it for America
he's the guy that's our doping control
like he are doing controlled he's are
what you sought a guy or what he's mad
at did all the drug tests for the
Olympics from like the 80s on right but
you not the guy that dopes up the
American is really clearly to say that
he doesn't dope on my piece of guy that
tests them right we should tell people
with Icarus is too if they don't know
what we're talking about so this would
be a standalone podcast it's a
documentary that Brian Fogle made where
he decided to Reise Reise ride his bike
in a race clean completely clean and
then do it on steroids to see what his
times would be how much how much benefit
he would have and in the process of him
filling this documentary the guy who
hooked him up this guy Gregory from
Russia who was the head unbeknownst to
him of the Russian state-sponsored
doping program he was like he thought he
was getting a guy who is it like the
Russian you sada that it was going to
tell him what the cheaters use but
turned out along the way everything got
exposed and he was like look I've did
this for 40 years I'd okay buddy
everybody on drugs and like he said
every [ __ ] single athlete that was in
the Olympics was on some [ __ ] and then
he explained how they did it in
everybody's like what the [ __ ] and then
they were gonna pull the Russians and
then the other thing that he exposed is
the the collusion between wada and the
ioc and that they all work for each
other and they switch [ __ ] roles and
go back and forth with each other and
that they're not going to punish the
russians and that yeah this but what
they're doing now is they kind of have
to because all of that movie i mean that
movie literally change the Olympics I
guess what I'm saying is when I did
bigger stronger faster and we're going
around talking to the experts you know a
lot of the experts they would mention
Don Catelyn and I'd be like what's up
with Don Catlin and they'd say oh man if
you get him to talk I mean the sports
world will just crumble and everybody
kept saying that like I heard it from
like 41 people houses are experts they
just said like nobody would believe in
sports if that guy exposed what he knew
and so that I interviewed Don Catlin but
he just laughed when I asked him that
he's like they don't know what they're
talking about you know kind of thing and
I said well Charles II Salus is an
expert he said the whole sports will
crumble if they if they knew what you
knew what do you know and he said I
don't know anything you know and so what
you're not you're never gonna get an
answer like that something has to get
exposed through a different way so right
I shouldn't I can't say without a [ __ ]
without a shadow beyond a shadow of a
doubt that that's the truth but I'm
suspicious of that guy I should say yeah
and suspicious of our system I don't
think they're the only ones doing it
there's no way that the only ones doing
that China had a record number of gold
medals when they hosted it but I think
we're doing it just as bad as they are I
wonder how many we're doing it better
obviously we're not getting caught I
mean do so so when you say we have
state-sponsored program
I don't think state-sponsored but I
think like there's some people doing
something somewhere there's some sort of
network song shenanigans look if there's
one BALCO there's ten there's got to be
more than one batter yeah you think so
there's got to be more than one guy
that's like yeah
telling people what to take
hmmm there's a lot of that [ __ ] out
there
[Applause]